dude I remember growing up in Louisiana
they had a they did an event
every year
and an event is like something where you
don't you know it's like regular time
but it's more special than that
somebody would fly in a plane through
the air
around town
and they would play Christmas music out
the plane
this was a small plane a crop duster
so they put on these jovial tunes and
they would hit the air
and so moms they would bring us outside
on the porch about maybe 6 40.
and say do you hear it do you hear
you here and they would just be like
dashing through this you know you know
it would be the song you hear and it
would just be it would blow your mind
and it lifted you up with that Christmas
spirit
and I thought that that was so special
that a town did that that they invested
in that sort of thing
and I think that that's important that
kind of stuff
because that you know who knows if that
moment right there might have you know
kept him magic alive in me
and made me believe in things because
you know Santa is something you believe
in but it's something that's just your
it's just your first kind of
it's kind of like your first romance in
a weird way
you know you're hopeful in your excited
and there's possibility and there's a
date there's December 25th
and it's just
you know it has all the elements of
romance but no sex
nobody getting sex
and there's something that you know
there's something special about that
because I think if you can make that
time romantic enough to a child in an
you know or you know you know romance
but non-sexual you know if you can make
it entertaining enough to a child in
that way then it can um they'll carry
that same ambiance
and the same belief of possibility into
the world
in other aspects man
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one